COLT MCANLIS: In this episode
of Cloud Performance Atlas
we take a look at App
Engine Scaling Settings
to optimize our instance count.
Will we find the
right trade-off?
Stay tuned to find out.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
In a previous episode, we helped
the developer of Partly Cloudy
Image Suite reduce
her instance count
with some clever
shifting of workload
from the server to the client.
While this brilliant solution
cut the number of active App
Engine instances
significantly, some folks
have pointed out
that we really should
have adjusted the scaling
values of the App Engine YAML
file instead.
Now in complete honesty,
I've never actually messed
with any of the
settings in detail,
so I had no idea what
they did, why they did it,
or why I should care about that.
But that's what we do here
on Cloud Performance Atlas--
we figure this stuff out.
As such, it was time to dig
into the Scaling Setting file
and figure out how they
influenced the instance
count of our text.
Now I made some nice
charts and things,
but before we get to that,
I have to take a moment
and talk about how
App Engine decides
to start a new instance.
I mean, we can't really
start tweaking these settings
unless we know what
we're touching.
See, the App Engine's serving
algorithms are constantly
deciding on whether it's
better to queue up a request
or spin up a new instance.
This takes into account
a significant number
of factors for this
decision, like request
queue depth, average queries
per second, average request
latency, et cetera,
et cetera, et cetera.
But to make things
more simple, let's
focus on the four
primary systems
that you can consider in your
configuration file, which
can directly impact the
decisions that App Engine makes
about spinning up new instances.
Number one is the number
of concurrent requests
per instance.
Number two, how long a request,
can sit in the work queue.
Number three, if there's any
resident instances available.
And number four, what type
of instances you're using.
In order to understand
how all of these things
played together, I decided
to run a little stress test
to see how many instances
we could spin up
on the default setting with
four seconds of static response
time.
Now, obviously this isn't
a real-world scenario.
Now, when we throw 100
threads of connections
at our application
for about 10 minutes,
we end up with a beautiful graph
like the Google Cloud Console
has that looks like this.
My completely
unrealistic scenario
topped out at
about 100 instances
to handle my work-- the
blue line right there.
So we can start tweaking
some of the scaling settings
and see how that value responds.
Let's start with an easy one--
concurrent requests.
In order to optimize performance
versus instance count,
you can control the max
number of connections
you have per instance.
The Max Concurrent
Request setting
allows you to
control this value.
The default for this is 8, which
we saw a graph for already.
I changed to 80 and
re-ran the test.
You can see that the
number of instances
dropped significantly from
100 to around 20 or so,
which is important
since this means
my bill has been cut by a
significant amount as well.
The trade here is
straightforward.
The higher the value,
the less number
of instances, you need
to spin up connections.
However, if you set it
too high, then you're
going to see latency
problems as your instance is
strapped for resources.
Or it may cause new
instances to be spun up
if you eclipse the available
memory of your machine.
Lowering this value
can help you find
the sweet spot between
the number of connections
per instance, the
resources needed
for your request,
and the resources
for your particular
instance class.
So let's reset that
back to default
and see what the Pending
Latency settings do.
See, when a request comes
in, App Engine's front ends
will place it in a queue
until an instance becomes
available to
service the request.
If there are no available
instances waiting around,
then App Engine has
to make a decision.
Either it waits for one of
the instances become available
or it starts up a new instance.
The values of min/max
pending latency
directly control how the
scheduler will allow a request
to wait in this queue before
spinning up new instances.
The higher the min
pending latency value,
the longer a request
will wait in the queue
before triggering a new
instance to be spawned.
Changing this from our default
value of 30 milliseconds
to 6 seconds, we can see
that the number of instances
generally drop compared
to base use case.
It looks like we're topping
out at about 65 instances
or so for this test.
Now max pending latency,
on the other hand,
is the time after
which App Engine
must start a new
instance, if a request
has been waiting this long.
Setting this value to 4
seconds doesn't really
see much change in the
total number of instances
that were spawning,
but it might just
be due to the constant load
that's being put on the system.
I mean it'll probably change
once the workloads become
a little bit more variable.
Now, all of these
settings so far
have dealt with the
requests themselves,
but we haven't really talked
about giving more resources
to the incidents.
It should be no surprise to you
that your App Engine instances
are running on some
physical piece of hardware
somewhere in the world,
and the slower the machine,
the longer it takes
to do heavy workloads,
leaving requests in the
request queue for longer.
The trick here is to request
the least powerful machine
possible that
handles your workload
and doesn't force new instances
to be created as a result.
The default for the instance
class variable is F1.
So let's test an F4
instance, and see
how that changes things up.
We can see that for our
particular workload,
changing this from F1
to F4 didn't really
do much to the overall
number of instances.
However, I'd expect that to
change if we were actually
CPU- or memory-bound instead
of just sleeping for 4 seconds.
OK, OK, OK.
So we've tweaked to
each setting and we
have a clear picture
of what it does
and how it impacts
our instance count.
So let's find the sweet spot.
This means that for our
4-second block of work,
we want the average
latency for a response
to be as close to 4
seconds as possible.
To do this, let's set
Instance Class to F4,
Max Concurrent Requests
to 80, Max Pending Latency
to 8 seconds, and Min
Pending Latency to 6 seconds.
The result gives us about 18
instances through our test
and only about 400 milliseconds'
latency being added
to each request on average.
Now from here we can start
tweaking the settings to make
trade-offs between the
number of instances
we're willing to pay for and
the latency overhead it causes
for our users, which is exactly
the spot that we want to be in.
However, this won't solve all
of your performance problems
in the Cloud.
That's why you should check
out the rest of the Cloud
Performance Atlas videos.
And remember, that when
it comes to your users,
every millisecond counts.
[MUSIC PLAYING]